nein das wollte ich ja gerade vermeiden
und witzel es ist so eine langweilige
arbeit
was jetzt 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 kombination
noch ein und zwar kann wasser genau mit
dem punkt wo man es einsetzt acht blöcke
weit also sieben blöcke weit fiel zum
schluss dem blog wo man den setzt also 8
das heißt wir sie dürfen die seiten
jetzt nicht acht lang machen das wäre
traumhaft sondern 9
weil sonst wird das wasser den rhein
fließt und dann wenn die ganzen mops tag
so komisch runter schwimmen und das
wollen wir natürlich nicht sondern wir
wollen dass die elendig verrecken
verrecken
ich glaube hier noch nicht fertig so
jetzt auch
sohn kurz auszählen 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
das gut 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 es auch gut 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 auch gut 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 ist auch gut
das heißt wir bauen das setzt sich
einfach an jeder seite drei fiel so hoch
und daran halten dach drüber
wir können das ja eigentlich erst mal
keine ahnung
hier kommt dann sag ich mal so das dach
hin also hier so die wände besser wissen
und da dann so das dach drauf
also ich hoffe ihr versteht das jetzt
ungefähr so was ich meine das ist da
dann auch quasi die komplette zeit
einfach dunkel ist
so und ansporn hier noch die mobs drin
und dann haben wir hier gut ist sondern
natürlich frei da haben wir in die
wasser abflüsse die kann ich auch direkt
bauen
ich hoffe mal dass ich jetzt oben dort
war falsch das ist jetzt richtig baue
wenn ihr in welche
verbesserungsvorschläge wyss bzw
themen über die ich reden kann bzw
allgemein irgendwas was sich hier besser
machen kann
bitte die kommentarfunktion nutzen da
unten einfach rein kritzeln wie immer
leidlich in erding von eurer mutter und
kaputt kritzelt mir dann einfach
irgendwas reimers wieder eventuell
helfen könnte ich bausteine steine
schneider eine spitzhacke und dafür
brauche ich jetzt muss man immer ihr so
eine blöde spitzhacken machen um diesen
verpackten cobblestone abzubauen
so achtet
128 jetzt tun wir die wieder weg nehmen
uns hier zwei sticks packen das war ein
so so ich glaube dass meist gesagt bei
wort in dieser folge ist so ganz einfach
ich hab gerade nicht so die kraft zu
reden
wegen weil immer noch erkältet schon oft
genug gesagt aber schalten natürlich
immer noch neue leute ein das
nichtwissen und fragen sich den helm
redest zu wenig kann man den kommentaren
zu beantworten wie zum beispiel auch
warum nutzen anders lag ich habe gesagt
ich fange dieses projekt mit diesem
texture pack an und werde es auch mit
diesem text speck beenden
ganz einfach ich möchte nicht einfach
zwischen den händlern das ist doch genau
der grund warum ich bei denen es auch
nicht einfach mittendrin ende bei der
today show dass ich da ein anderes
texture pack nehme sondern einfach die
sache beibehalten wir das konzept der
concept kann man das nicht nennen aber
ich denke ihr wisst was ich meine
mein gott ich kann darüber quatschen was
mittlerweile ein eigenes spiel
entwickelt und zwar heißt dieser
spielszene c oder 60 c c oder 0x 10 c
oder irgendwie sowas richtig richtig
komischer name ich denke es wird nachher
noch einen richtigen namen enthalten
erhalten und das ist erst mal nur sagen
sondern anfangs immer quasi song
projektname um es mal ordentlich zu
beschreiben
und das ist halt minecraft aufgebaut
aber halt auch mit waffen und alles
mögliche also interessanter denke ich
also für mich jetzt erst mal
interessanter aus minecraft
natürlich kann man sagen ey vom ein
kraft nach gemacht aber naja ich finde
eigentlich dass gott guckt euch das an
die koppel die steine seien die steine
haben komplett direkt in die wie egal
gereicht ich werde das spiel auf jeden
fall anzocken beziehungsweise mir auf
jeden fall mal anschauen so den eimer
brauche ich und ich werde mir darum
jetzt erstmal so eine sonde so eine
quelle machen sage ich mal verpasste
einmal ein bisschen sand ob gott nein
jetzt runter auch schon monster ach du
heilige ein das wollte ich gerade
vermeiden
nur nicht mehr sterben weil ich möchte
den diamanten und dann entscheiden weil
das ist einfach so viel einfacher mit
enchanted geht einfach so viel schneller
das springt er wieder hier ehrlich alles
in der luft
ja ok ich muss dem wahrscheinlich nicht
ein bisschen auszurichten bisschen viel
so jetzt kommt er aber nichts mehr so
was soll ich noch mal machen auch so
erstmal hier skeletten auf jeden fall
wer war das da oben schön
nun seht ihr mal wie ich eine monster
falle bauen versuche tun machen sein
haben
hast du das habe ich mir die dinge ist
und in sand statt schnee ich frag mich
gott schon so hell bei mir voll die
kluge frage gestellt so hier oben drauf
ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie das geht
also erstmal ein erst mal so eine tolle
unendliche quelle
ich will sprinten und dann packen wir da
oben einfach noch ein wasserfall und
jahr viele wussten gar nicht dass man so
auch eine unendliche quelle machen kann
es geht und ich finde es deutlich
angenehmer so jetzt guckt euch das an
ihre perfekte berechnungen perfekt
bagdad an jeder seite da so hin und dann
schwimmen wir uns mache alle schönen
abschluss wo wir die da unten in der
toilette in dem ende von dingen es
einfach abknallen können bitten wir sie
töten
passt so hier noch ein
wie möchte das netz ich muss ja
eigentlich noch mal komplett immens viel
sand fahren wenn man sich das jetzt mal
so anguckt hier
ich würde sagen dann machen wir dann
einfach jetzt mal eben ich habe ja in
eine schaufel das jetzt einfach mal
sandfarben hier nebenan wenn wir mehr
direkt so wir haben ja hier kein sand
quatsch und dann europa das zweite
kaputt dann machen uns aus dem sand
einfach sense doch obwohl wir eigentlich
auch direkt mit der spitzhacke sandstorm
abbauen können aber das wäre natürlich
viel zu kompliziert ich will jetzt auch
gerne auf nacht machen und schauen was
passiert bisher sorgt das so
funktioniert nicht mehr das vorgestellt
habe
ey voll langweilig die post ab ja ich
weiß nicht worüber ich rede könnte
ich bin ja zurzeit wohl dass er gerade
sieht in paris in paris machen da gerade
urlaub das habe ich glaube ich gar nicht
irgendwo verkündet sondern nur hier so
bei wasteland wir mal so ein bisschen
deswegen kommen währenddessen gerade
keine mod reviews snapshot vorstellung
und so weiter und ganz einfach weil ich
gerade spontan mix aufnehmen können weil
wegen grund gerade genannt und kaputt so
ich mache ich das jetzt erstmal so das
ist genug
wo es fiktiv da so ein toller helikopter
jahr ist ja auch nicht so dass
mittlerweile täglich zehn milliarden von
den teilen rumfliegen ich weiß nicht
warum ob irgendwo in unserem kleinen
kaff eine bombenwarnung ist immer so
oder was sie für einen grund haben aber
auf jeden fall muss irgendwas wichtiges
sein wenn ihr zehn milliarden mal am tag
rumfliegen als ich damals meinen london
war war das cluster ich fliegen sie
wirklich im minuten takt über london und
die londoner guckt man gar nicht
irgendein himmel ob wenn da so ein
helikopter wirklich nah bei dir den kopf
darüber fliegt die nehmen das einfach so
hin sagen ja das ist london und mehr
dann halt doch nicht aber ich meine wenn
du ihnen beim täglichen helikopter sich
jemand durch auch keinen bock mehr drauf
so jetzt zeige ich das mal die werden
dann hier ein gedrängt habe ich hier rum
natürlich noch sonntag sage ich mal
sportlich eine schere
was zu mampfen werden wir leben
verlieren genau da
brot gut habe ich nur gesagt schwer
vergessen wenn man hier befinden wir uns
gerade in diesem loch drumrum einfach
gramm
ach jetzt auch schon ja ich weiß es geht
alles sehr sehr langweilig in western
weil ich nicht neu entdecke und weil ich
einfach wirklich hier gerade nur am
abbauen bin und das hörte sich an als
wäre hier in die lava oder so aber war
der erfahrung vielleicht sehr schnell
versteht nicht mehr gut wir auch immer
so die fallen danach her da oben runter
ich habe schon wieder ein bisschen
fenster und ich kann das ja mal kurz
einfach so bis den farben weiß zwar
nicht was das bringt wenn ich mir jetzt
hier noch seine farben machen aber es
egal so einfach aufgrund von
gleichberechtigung machen wir auch und
dann können wir eigentlich sogar erstmal
diesem turm da drum rum bauen wartete
ich zeige euch das mal da oben
oh gott jetzt hat man immer das wasser
muss nicht schön aussehen das kann ich
auch mit zwang machen mit sand das für
falsch
egal
wir machen das jetzt so super so da
fallen jetzt alle runter wenn sie da
oben sind warte ich zeige euch das mal
ganz kurz von oben kann ja noch ein paar
blöcke verbauen so die spawnen quasi
hier fallen dann alle darunter und ich
brauchte nur einen schlag für die und
dann sterben die direkt also so wie ich
mir das vorstelle
denn natürlich nicht ich hab das alles
direkt zur klappt hier wie ich mir das
vorstelle
aber das wird sich dann noch zeigen
denke ich du kannst vecchi kommt der
innenwand in und hier dann einfach
komplett waren
damit hier einfach kein licht rein kommt
auf jeden fall noch sand und ton obwohl
die wände kann ich ja theoretisch aus
anmachen und alexej schneller geht es
ans zu fahren als sense dann bietet sich
das natürlich an und ich wollte jetzt
doch eigentlich ein aufnahmestopp machen
was ich auch sofort machen werde
allerdings möchte ich noch ganz kurz dem
land einen weg verbauen
dann wird diese folge einfach ein
bisschen länger denke aber das kümmert
euch nicht das gemacht mich nicht und
dann passt warum einfach mal etwas
längere folge
du kommst auch noch weg berg und dann
müsste man eigentlich auch schon fast
fertig sein mit den kompletten
challenges ein okay wenn wir selbst aus
dem titel scheiß machen wie macher einen
stonebridge war auch cool kommt mal
wieder gewachsen
ein paar davon
da wieder hin pflanzen die ein loch das
kann ich essen lecker - sondern pflanzen
warum jetzt noch was
wo ich hoffe mal das funktioniert alles
und wisst ihr was das wetter richtig
behindert wenn es nachher nicht
funktioniert ich meine ich würde
trotzdem abhaken weil dann ich das jetzt
so lange daran und das ist für mich nur
monster falle wenn das nicht
funktioniert dann liegt nicht an mir das
liegt an minecraft das ist dann einfach
so so ich würde sagen das war's dann
erst mal von dieser volk dies jetzt noch
nicht so lang geworden fällt mir kommt
auf 17 minuten ungefähr
ich baue da einfach noch so ein paar
stützen und damit dass ein bisschen noch
was aussieht moment war das so also
stützen im sinne von so damit dass ein
teil nicht einfach so eine luft schwebt
sondern schon okay schwebt in der luft
sand kann so was in ihm leben halten
aber ich würde sagen das war es dann
auch eigentlich erst mal von dieser
folge ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen
tag wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr das video
mit einem daumen hoch bewerten denn
nicht damit einem daumen runter und dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal